have you ever wanted to be in a cartoon
they have it easier than we do that's
for sure the characters in your favorite
shows never seem to experience boring
days and the world around them always
seems so wonderful and imaginative
animation is an idealized stylized form
of reality where anything can happen and
entertainment is at the forefront of the
lived experience if you're understanding
the appeal behind what we're talking
about you'll definitely be interested in
hearing about scp-6080
a strange anomaly known as eric's
cartoon box the story of eric's cartoon
box is elaborate and complex but
catalog's one of the foundation's most
imaginative and surreal anomalies on
file it started on parawatch.net a
message board dedicated to the
supernatural and paranormal that the
foundation likes to keep tabs on in
their spare time while sifting through
countless fake posts about being
abducted by aliens or hunting for
bigfoot the foundation noticed something
less conventional that caught their eye
a series of posts that talked about a
cursed vhs tape of the mid-90s classic
nickelodeon cartoon rocco's modern life
now a cursed cartoon seems like your
standard internet horror fiction fair
something the foundation could easily
dismiss as a story crafted by an amateur
author but what caught their attention
were the pictures of strange entities
that appeared as a result of watching
the tape as well as information on how
the original poster obtained the tape it
seemed oddly specific a tape purchased
on ebay through a seller named tune
collector the foundation conducted a
brief investigation and found that tune
collector was a resident of bakersfield
california named jacob sawyer who had
gone missing sometime in the past inside
his house the foundation found several
vhs tapes and dvd cases as well as a
television a hard drive on sawyer's
computer contained 161 hours of brief
edited videos all reviewing and
commenting on various cartoons seems
like sawyer had a video essay hobby but
the foundation was unable to locate any
of this content on major video hosting
sites in sawyer's basement the
foundation discovered a large worn out
cardboard box on its right side were the
words eric's cartoon box written in
black sharpie on its front was a
simplistic smiley face also drawn in
sharpie originally the foundation
thought it was just an ordinary box but
the object quickly proved itself to be
alive capable of speaking despite a lack
of vocal cords and also possessing a
large degree of mobility propelling
itself short distances to move when the
foundation first came across
scp-6080 in sawyer's basement the object
was clearly distressed
scp-6080 and all the other items found
were taken into foundation custody and
moved to site 433 where they would be
researched by dr rowan raster one of the
foundation's leading figures in the
study of animated anomalous media and
art rasters research found that
scp-6080 when emotionally distressed
could bend reality to alter their
surroundings which were transformed into
reflections of its psyche raster
discovered that there were a few ways to
pacify scp-6080
but the most practical method was to
evoke a sense of nostalgia in the object
by placing it in a familiar environment
to ensure that the box is kept passive
scp-6080 is kept inside a containment
chamber resembling a child's bedroom an
environment
scp-6080 finds comforting on top of
their reality bending abilities
scp-6080 also produces dvds and vhs
tapes labeled
scp-6080-1 the foundation would later
discover that the tapes found within
sawyer's home and the cursed rocco's
modern life tape discussed on
parawatch.net were all products of
scp-6080
but what's so special about the cartoon
reproductions made by 6080 on the
outside there are unaltered copies of
animated children's television shows and
films and their contents are exactly the
same as their ordinary counterparts
however once an instance of
scp-6080-1 is viewed the subject
watching it will experience a reality
altering anomalous experience dubbed by
the research team as a re-run event
sometimes the rerun event occurs
immediately though research has shown
that as much time as three weeks can
pass before one occurs rerun events
often reflect visual or thematic
elements of the media that induce them
and their severity ranges from
inconsequential to dangerous and harmful
to their subjects because of the variety
found in a re-run event's content it is
difficult to generalize them but we'll
be sure to get into the specifics of a
few later on still if the event isn't
immediately dangerous to the subject the
foundation discovered that a rerun event
may leave involved persons with
lingering physical and psychological
alterations some of which are unable to
be fully alleviated or treated even with
amnesics soon after scp-6080 was brought
into site-433 and the immediate
characteristics of the anomaly were
recorded an interview between the box
and researcher rowan raster was held
rowan tried to make sure that the
anomaly was as comfortable as possible
but scp-6080 continued to shuffle
against the floor rapidly unsettled in
their new environment
scp-6080 wanted to get out and the
object continued to stress themselves
out to the point where its speech
degraded into unintelligibility the
lights in the containment chamber began
flickering on and off and the face on
the front of the box rapidly flipped
between different expressions rowan
tried to continue to get through to
scp-6080
and eventually they began to speak they
said that they were scared and that they
missed someone that they called eric
scp-6080 once calmed down explained that
eric was the center of their universe in
their own words
scp-6080 felt when it first started
existing that their sole purpose for
being here on earth was to exist for
eric they remembered waking up in a
bedroom filled with toys and posters and
immediately knowing the feeling that
they knew what they were made for and
who they were made by
at first this was overwhelming and
scp-6080 began to freak out but eric
showed concern and the box realized that
they didn't want to upset him the most
important thing for scp-6080
was to not upset eric when raster asked
if they could describe eric the box was
unable to and said that whenever they
tried to talk about eric's appearance
people became confused they said that
eric's skin was blue and that he had a
purple nose with dark red eyes and four
thin strands of hair on top of his head
from the way they described eric he
sounded exactly like a cartoon character
raster asked if this was how
scp-6080 always saw people and that
seemed to be the case
scp-6080 then explained how they used
their abilities to make eric happy
namely through producing tapes of eric's
favorite cartoons and then playing
inside the worlds of the shows together
and this continued for a while
scp-6080 and eric would meet the
characters from their favorite shows and
adventure through their worlds and the
two developed a powerful bond but
eventually as
scp-6080 explained eric left one day the
box woke up and their friend was gone
scp-6080 even searched for eric's
friends but found that they were gone
too without eric
scp-6080 was alone and they panicked
they ran outside the house and began
asking anyone they could find if they
knew where eric went naturally the
people scp-6080 spoke to were terrified
and scp-6080 quickly became overwhelmed
by the chaos of the outside world and
then they found jacob sawyer sawyer was
at first just as scared of scp-6080 as
everyone else was but once scp-6080
opened its flaps and revealed a trove of
old tapes sawyer smiled to himself and
told the box that it would be useful
before picking them up and taking them
to his house
scp-6080 was scared and attempted to
flee from sawyer the more time the box
spent with sawyer the sicker it felt
when sawyer threw the box in the empty
white walls of his basement
scp-6080 was forced by jacob to open
themselves up and produce tapes for
months this is how scp-6080 lived alone
in a white-walled room with white floors
and white ceilings being forced open and
used as a dispenser for the tapes which
sawyer would sell online
scp-6080 stopped their account and began
crying a substance that resembled
blueberry syrup raster put a stop to the
interview realizing that the object was
clearly experiencing a form of trauma
after a break raster asked scp-6080 if
they knew what happened to sawyer the
box explained that one day sawyer rushed
down into the basement and demanded
scp-6080 to explain what it was doing to
the cartoons it made apparently some of
the buyers were realizing that scp-6080s
tapes were anything but normal sawyer
brutalized the box and pulled the dvd
from inside them but when sawyer watched
the dvd for himself all scp-60 heard
from beneath the living room was a sharp
burst of static and a horrible scream
after that jacob was gone
scp-6080 couldn't recall what tape they
had produced that caused sawyer to
disappear nor was one matching the box's
description found inside the house after
the interview the foundation began its
testing with
scp-6080 inside its containment chamber
scp-6080 would produce a tape a d-class
personnel would watch it and the ensuing
rerun event was recorded during testing
scp-6080 was escorted from the room so
as to not cause it emotional distress
most of these tests were routine a
d-class would watch an episode of a
cartoon such as chalk zone or the
rugrats and strange reality altering
events would occur for example after
watching an episode of the rugrats where
chucky had difficulty differentiating
his dreams from reality d 1711
experienced a re-run event in which he
was disoriented d-1711 claimed
everything in the room looked tall and
that they needed to sleep off the
effects of the anomaly after laying in
the bed the chamber's lights turned blue
and purple and a humanoid entity wearing
a researcher's outfit was seen facing
the corner of the room against the wall
the figure disappeared as quickly as it
appeared with laughter heard in the
distance as soon as the figure was gone
d-1711 jolted awake and began screaming
after this the researcher observing the
experiment rushed in and like a
concerned parent began comforting d-1711
the researcher assured the d-class that
nothing in a dream could hurt them
because it isn't real which was a direct
quote from the rugrats episode d-1711
watched after this the d-class and the
researcher came out of their trance
state wondering how they got inside the
containment chamber and what they were
doing there the rerun event had finished
and d 1711 explained that while they
were asleep they dreamed events similar
to the dream shown in the rugrats
episode this is just one example of how
odd and surreal rerun events can be
another test involving an obscure
cartoon by the name of king resulting in
the entirety of site 433 undergoing
changes that made it look as if it were
a location from the show itself however
the most notable rerun event occurred
when the foundation tested a tape of
cartoon all-stars to the rescue a
special featuring cartoon characters
from various shows banding together to
talk about the dangers of children using
drugs in order to conduct this test d
9926 was sent to a quarantine community
away from site 433 with only a helmet
mounted camera and a communication
headset 10 hours after watching the tape
d 99 26 slept inside a bedroom of the
vacant building the foundation had
brought him to he was woken by the sound
of a doorknob jittering and then several
knocks dean 9926 got up from the bed and
opened the door to find four crude
looking entities resembling cartoon
characters from the special one was
kermit the frog who was puppeteered by a
man in a gray hoodie another was a
cardboard cutout of bug's bunny there
was a tall mascot-like garfield costume
and a sentient alf plush the four
entities crowded d-9926
and began singing to him in a shrill
high-pitched voice a song about the
dangers of doing drugs d 99-26 was
confused but the trance induced by the
anomaly made it difficult for him to
think straight then from the open
windowsill in the room came a black boot
attached to a long leg a fifth entity
made its way into the room crawling
through the windowsill it was a tall
gray-skinned humanoid with wrinkled
trousers a creased shirt and a large
necktie as much as d d9926 could
understand the grey entity was not from
a cartoon the grey entity signaled
d-9926 towards them and the two left the
building and the strange cartoon
entities behind outside the environment
was strange it was dark out with only
dim street lights illuminating the
spaces between trees at a low angle the
asphalt path the duo walked on slowly
transitioned to a field of grass the
grey entity explained that the very
nature of the environment was built
around the message of the cartoon which
was trying to get d 9926 to avoid using
drugs somehow
d9926 needed to find a way to get out as
the two moved through the forest area
d9926 and the grey entity continued to
recognize something was wrong gray
explained that it didn't understand
where they were either and that's when d
9926's rerun event began altering
reality it was pulled away from the
place it regularly existed and into
reality
d9926 did not understand but he was
short on options both of them smelled
something horrible and the area around
them was starting to resemble the real
world less and less the sky above the
forest was smoky orange red and in the
distance dean 9926 could see a
luminescent object resembling a window
recessed into a concrete wall the two
also heard music and as they moved
through this dreamlike world they came
across a building in the distance which
was small enough for them to climb the
roof of on the roof there appeared to be
a parking lot and beyond it more forest
as if they never elevated from the
ground in the first place the two
continued walking as the parking lot
sloped downwards they recognized what
appeared to be a city in the distance
dean knew that with the altered state of
reality this city was going to be
anything but normal but he felt
compelled to keep moving it was the only
thing the two of them could do
d 9926 and the grey entity began talking
about the nature of the reality they
found themselves in and the entity
explained that it felt that trusting its
gut and exploring anything that stood
out was probably the right thing to do
in a place that made little actual sense
they concluded that the location they
were inside had some sort of feelings
and goals and they just had to go along
with its own internal logic in order to
find a way out in the distance the red
lights of the city twinkled in the
darkness they continued walking after 30
minutes the red lights of the city
illuminated all of their surroundings
and they began to see the edifices of
concrete buildings on the other side of
the road they were walking on d 9926
didn't notice them at first but when the
entity pointed them out
d-9926 realized they were standing in
the middle of a mass of buildings with
rubble and litter strewn on the streets
beneath them gray wondered if they could
use them as shelter the two didn't
realize that they were being watched by
a figure in the distance
d 9926 was still confused the city was
empty gray seemed oddly optimistic about
their situation and things weren't
looking like they were going to return
to normal anytime soon gray commented
that they were somewhat interested in
exploring a location different from the
realities and dreams they were used to
exploring after minutes of nothing the
duo came across a dead body laying on
top of a rusted metal wheelbarrow
d9926 who was familiar with seeing
sights like these sighed and continued
moving gray told them he could simply
walk away into the darkness where they
could forget about this place and emerge
somewhere else d9926
wondered if the entity really had that
power they came across more bodies and
continued forward if this entity could
really whisk d 9926 away to another
place he was seriously considering it
life as a d-class was unimaginably
dehumanizing the figure watching the two
of them continued to observe from a
rooftop suddenly a large sheet metal
shelving unit fell from the overhanging
roof of a building tipped from its edge
by the observing figure the shelving
unit hit gray directly and severely
injured the entity on impact d 9926 ran
he ran through the buildings only
catching glimpses of the orange figure
wielding a thick pipe running across the
rooftops beside him the chase continued
through the insides of the buildings and
once dean 9926 caught a glimpse of the
pursuing figure he ran back out the
entire time he heard the figures
high-pitched breathing audibly chasing
after him more bodies more red lighting
and endless city all while being pursued
dean 9926 found rest inside a warehouse
which he ran through in an attempt to
escape the entity at the far side of the
warehouse was a room resembling
scp-6080s containment chamber but
heavily damaged and littered with trash
the television set in the room switched
on showed an all-white room similar to
the basement
scp-6080 was found in the door to the
room was about to be opened and
d9926 screamed before smashing the tv
with a book he threw from across the
room upon shattering the screen the
camera feed went dark when it resumed
d-9926 found himself in a red misty area
with a figure that had been pursuing him
standing right in front of him the two
stared at each other before the figure
lunged forward at dean 9926
but then it suddenly stopped and the
voice of
scp-6080 was heard the box called out to
the figure which it recognized as
something that resembled jacob sawyer
scp-6080 ordered the sawyer entity to
leave d 9926 alone except this time
scp-6080 wasn't a cardboard box
they were a pale skinned child drawn
like a cartoon wearing ordinary clothes
the box realized that this place was a
manifestation of its own traumatic
experience as it slowly realized that
the entity resembling sawyer was stuck
in its own mind the box and the entity
fought each other punching with large
cartoon-like fists until the sawyer
entity fell to the ground coughing up
blood
scp-6080 realized that this wasn't
actually sawyer like everything this was
all a manifestation of the damage that
sawyer caused and with that the entity
left its own body flattening until all
that was left was its empty skin dean
9926 thanked scp-6080 for saving him and
the two introduced themselves to one
another
scp-6080 offered to take d-9926 away
from the foundation forever he took off
his recording equipment and the two
walked away into the sunset inside
scp-6080's containment chamber the
object and d-9926 were nowhere to be
found instead there was a single disc
containing a message from
scp-6080 to the foundation
scp-6080 told the foundation that they
were coming to terms with what they
experienced in their life and that now
they were in a place where they could
exist without issue behind them was a
playground where
scp-6080 could act like a kid again
something they never got to experience
as much as they wanted to they told the
foundation that dean 9926 was safe and
happy somewhere else and that they
shouldn't look for either of them
because they'd never find them for now
all
scp-6080 needed to do was to play on the
swings and live at peace with themselves
until they could grow up inside the disc
that the message was contained on was a
sticky note that simply read i hope you
understand now go check out
scp-3082 neverland's lost boys and girls
and
scp-974 tree house predator for more of
the scp foundation's anomalous child's
play